okay can we talk about hairstyles yeah
[Music]
Harry Styles fans get excited the singer
will be on The Late Late Show with James
Corden for a whole week starting May 15
we get to be an artist-in-residence and
what is he going to do well you've got
to have known us for a very long time as
we've known young Harold since he was 17
years old and I knew Louis because his
mum was a chaperone on a TV show I've
done they would come over to our house
and we'd have like pizza and play fifa
and my my wife would feel like she was
babysitting all of us
Harry was at my wedding and and I loved
him dearly I'm so incredibly proud of
now he's just coped with this crazy sort
of fishbowl of an existence that he's
had for the last five years do you think
of any I don't give him any love advice
are you joking needs no advice for me he
knows what he's doing equally exciting
another round of carpool karaoke this
time with Katy Perry
the segment will air May 22nd during
Corden's primetime special on CBS look
I'm a huge fan of hers both as a person
and an artist she has so many songs
which has just made who hasn't sung raw
at the top of their voice in the car and
good morning right sing it every morning
like it's gonna be great I'm so excited
yeah I know it's gonna be amazing I'm so
looking forward to just being in her
orbit what's your favorite of hers that
you're most excited what do you do role
I work I kissed a girl I liked it
you know everything yeah yeah yeah it'll
be amazing
[Music]
you